walking into a sequel as
hotly-anticipated as Deadpool - is scary
since the very notion of a flick that
follows up the hyper successful original
Deadpool raises weighty questions will
it be as funny raunchy and action-packed
can Ryan Reynolds really strike gold
twice as the Merc with a mouth and if we
just saw Josh Brolin as Thanos and
Avengers infinity war can we actually
enjoy him as cable your time's up you
dumb well that's just lazy writing take
a deep breath Deadpool fans we now have
answers to your questions ahead of it's
May 18th release Deadpool 2 premiered
early screenings to critics who have
wasted no time in revealing their
thoughts about the film that also stars
za z beats as Domino Terry Crews is
bedlam Lewis tan as shatter star Morena
Baccarin as Vanessa
Julian Dennison is Russell stefan kappa
sick as colossus Leslie Uggams as blind
al Caron Sony as dopinder Phil skarsgård
as zeitgeist and Rob Delaney as Peter
and first reactions are promising
proving that yes sequels can be as good
or better than the original Screen Rant
news editor Molly Freeman said she
enjoyed the film more than its
predecessor tweeting so I liked Deadpool
2 more than the first movie I think it's
more ambitious and it pays off there's
plenty of humor action and drama and the
movie balances it well cable and Domino
are standouts I love them and I can't
wait for x-force plus there are some fun
surprises
however Freeman mentioned that the
sequel quote makes a narrative decision
that is not great of course she didn't
spoil it by mentioning details might she
be talking about scandal embroiled actor
TJ Miller who portrays weasel in
Deadpool - Matt singer of screen crush
had a similar experience watching the
movie since he wasn't a huge fan of the
original film he tweeted slow to start
but all this stuff with x-force and
cable and Peter works surprisingly well
another critic who really disliked the
og Deadpool but was impressed by the
sequel was up Roxas Mike Ryan who
tweeted Deadpool to beat me into
submission until I was actually enjoying
myself also it features my now favorite
post credit scene I'm still legit
shocked that I enjoyed this movie Indy
wires Kate herb Lind also mentioned the
mysterious after movie scene tweeting
Deadpool - I'll say this it
the hell out of that our rating and the
cameos and the post-credits scenes indie
filmmaker sammy paul says fans will want
to stay after the credits and praise the
sequel for managing to be both
subversive and weirdly sweet while still
having all the hilarity and
self-awareness of the first film
Collider editor-in-chief Steven
Weintraub mirrored that sentiment
writing happy to report Deadpool - is a
lot of fun and had me laughing beginning
to end stuff after the credits is
awesome all the people added to the film
were perfectly cast cinema blend
managing director Sean O'Connell called
Deadpool - the perfect sequel tweeting
that it doubles down on everything the
fans loved about the original and fixes
some of that film's issues huge huge
laughs that play the audience like a
fiddle Ryan Reynolds destroys his weight
great action fantastic comic nods a
killer ride but arguably the best and
boldest reaction to Deadpool - came from
Vox senior reporter Alex Abbott Santos
who definitively stated Deadpool - is
better than infinity war find out for
yourself when Deadpool - hits theaters
on May 18th it lives up to the hype + +
stop it - you killed it thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel
+ check out all this other cool stuff we
know you'll love -
[Music]